[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
hey guys anna welcome back to my show
this is um powered by icon plus a quick
news announcement for you so
icon is joining the pokestop ecosystem
so polka dot power chains
um carla moonbeam edgware plasm
will be the first being integrated into
icons btp interoperability solutions so
always a lot of dpi news coming out icon
at the moment
now this is um sponsored by blockfy so
quick shout out to them you can get up
to i think it's 8.6
interest on your usdc so i use them give
them a go they're pretty cool
now joining me today is a pretty
interesting
guest i've been very excited to speak to
him um it is the head
of the bitcoin family dd the family that
invested absolutely
everything and bitcoin was just at uh
nine i think it was 900
so let's bring him in didi welcome to
the show how are you doing
hi leah thank you for having me on your
show man it's amazing i'm doing amazing
i'm in mexico playing the comment
i have the view of an amazing beach and
i'm an amazing woman in crypto
so my name is already perfect good i
love it your energy is always
so upbeat and it's so brilliant and
i just want to learn more about your
story because
you put was it absolutely everything the
house the cars
just everything into bitcoin yeah
everything
you know i started mining bitcoin in
and then in 2013 14 it was this huge
treasure i started not to believe
anymore in bitcoin i lost my trust
and then in 2016 i picked up again and
then and that was the moment
and after i lost my father of cancer and
i needed to change life and i started to
pick up everything again and i saw the
community
growing and that was the moment for me
to go all in and then yeah we sold our
house
i sold two companies i sold two cars
my motorbike the kids clothes the kids
toys the kids crossed
my wife's 70 pairs of shoes i took
pension funds
i took the kids savings i cooked our
savings we went
all in we just went living on a campsite
we went all
bitcoin and then we had the bull run of
and then life changed into a life
let's say a roller coaster ride as a
bitcoin family
i'm just so blown away i just think
that's insane
so just i want to go back a little bit
before i before i ask you about
you know the stress of doing all of that
but before i get into that how did you
first hear about bitcoin because you
said you were mining in 2013 right
yeah you know i grew up just like a
normal year i was very mutualistic
i was very egoistic i had this mosque
you know work walking around the world
the end of the globe and showing who you
are but you not are
but at that time i built up some
companies and one of those companies
there was an internship and this guy
comes into the company and he's like
did you ever hear about bitcoin i didn't
know what your internship can be about
it
what what do you suggest we do uh yeah
you can mine bitcoins maybe i can build
a mining rig and then we start to mine
bitcoins that will be my project
okay that's perfect let's do it so um
instead of just y miner i bought for
thirty thousand use the
dollar and miners and we started to
empty one
office and that empty became a mining
office so we started buying all the
mining rigs
and that was in 2013 and that was my
first connection to bitcoin it was like
you know i got fascinated by the story
you know that it was
disrupting the monetary system but i got
also fascinated because i want to become
a millionaire
at that time in my life i was a young
guy wanting to become a millionaire and
you know it was a revolution that could
make me a millionaire
and that was for me the trigger and then
i said to the guy okay let's do it
and we tried and we involved some more
friends that had more knowledge about
technical stuff and all that stuff and
we had a lot of
heat in the office we didn't know how to
handle that so we called the wheat
yeah we call the weed growers from the
netherlands and we told them how do you
handle the heat while you
grow your wheat plant uh yeah we do it
like this so we cop a death system into
the minor
office and that is how we started to
play around with mining bitcoins and at
the crash
and we changed from bitcoins to dogecoin
so we met
millions of bitcoins and then in 2014 we
had this huge crash
in december my father called me and he
said diddy i diagnosed cancer
we have one more year to live and that
is when i stopped everything you know i
hired managers to run the companies i
didn't pay attention to bitcoin anymore
i just invested all my time in the last
year with my father
and when he died in 2016 then again it
all started then it started again i saw
the forbes growing
so more and more people talking about
bitcoin i saw the price increasing
and then again was the step for me to
talk to my wife and tell her
maybe we should just travel the world
and go all in
so okay so everyone wants to be a
millionaire and
when you know bitcoin i mean i first
heard about bitcoin i think it was also
2013.
but i didn't have the same mentality as
you i wasn't like oh yeah that sounds
like something that which could get me
to becoming a millionaire so
what convinced you what was it was it
the technology or would you say
it's a little bit of luck tell me no no
at that moment we were already
because i had a huge burnout after the
funeral of all that stuff in 2016.
so i decided to start to travel with my
world with my family across the world we
went to thailand and to
to get a mental physical mindset reset
you know i needed a break
with the b of bitcoin but then during
that break
um i found out i was so happy i was more
happy than i had all the employees and
the companies i was just on the beach
building the sand castle with my kids
and that made me happy so we we kind of
roll into the system where we were
traveling through asia
vietnam the philippines indonesia and we
saw so many poor people
that didn't have an address that
couldn't fulfill the kyc
requirement to get a bank account and at
the same time i saw the beautiful asset
bitcoin group that was giving them
exactly that is so for me that trip of
the first three months was
perfectly timed i saw that more than
eighty percent of the world was
dissonant of the monetary system
i saw the solution i saw a revolution i
saw happiness on myself and my family so
for me it was all puzzles were falling
into a place and that was the perfect
time that was bad
just go all in i started to believe in
bitcoin and uh you know so sorry
there is really something to be said
about minimalism and
just getting rid of everything so given
you guys you know you found so much
peace on this journey
was it hard to convince your wife and
you know just to give up everything go
well then you said you even
even your children their savings you put
into bitcoin
was that hard to convince her
i uh of course that took a few my times
and put on the beach and a few bacardi
cokes
but my wife was not that was not the
maturistic part of the family it was
more me that always was in the home for
uh for
money and my wife was also already
doing yoga meditation she was more the
factor that kept the normal standard in
the family you know and
so for her it was i think for her the
biggest part was the
the leading by example you know as a
family if you have children
you can continue the life of your head
and your kids will copy your behavior
will copy that lifestyle
and i wanted to break that lifestyle my
wife wanted to show the kids as well we
need to break this circle
so that our kids get a better future we
need to prepare them for the different
future
decentralized future a future where you
don't need
ownership of a house or a car or a bike
or a bank account
that is what we need to prepare the kids
for so the passion for my wife
is always about the children and so for
her for her it was also easy to take the
step because it was
about leading by example for the kids
don't go and run and accumulate
don't go and run an acute wealth but
start to accumulate happiness
day by day you can force your kids to
run the hamster wheel and to make money
money money
or you can have them run the hamstring
and making happiness every day
and there was a switch that was for her
the main reason to accept the
crazy idea of selling the house and
everything from bitcoin
but you know it but you're you're moving
right so when we first
were chatting you were in portugal now
you're in mexico it's the goal
to just keep traveling and keep going
or is it to find a base no it's um
it's it's both it's been day by day we
don't have a plan we are the most
unstructurized company you will ever
meet we don't even know
where we will end up tomorrow or the day
after we we we just go with the flow but
we have the
opinion and the vision that ownership of
real estate a house
is not needed to live life you know the
future of technology is evolving so fast
that a house will become an own entity
on the blockchain a car will be a
self-driven car on the blocking
i will be stepping in the car driving
from a to b and paying
the kilometers i driven and this car
will be driving to the garage to
rip yourself and pay that guy again with
the wallet and this is the same with
houses this is the vision we have about
the future and we
why would i now tie myself to a house to
real estate
it has like a return of a business that
is really in my opinion
well i could be invested full of bitcoin
that has the biggest return investment
and that is how i show my kids
you know you don't need that house you
don't need a house to feel safe
i know we were we we grew up in the 90s
and you were taught
in the schools you need to have a big
house and then you need to provide for
your family and then you get the safety
network and you feel
relaxed no i feel relaxed when i'm free
to go
wherever i want whenever i want if they
close the stores
and the restaurants and the lock down in
portable i want to be going
and that's what we have i'm going to
mexico everything is open
life is normal that is the freedom
bitcoin and blockchain for me is more
about freedom than it is about
accumulating wealth and i think that is
what we want to show our kids the
community
and everybody else in the world i
totally agree with you and
and i absolutely admire it so much and
when i when i you know learned about you
guys and figured figured out you know
you you are moving from place to place
the first thing which came to mind which
i've been dying to ask you
is how does it work then with like your
kids education now before you answer
i totally i think i know you're gonna
say anyway but like i totally think that
the education system is trash
anyway i think that it teaches you um
the absolute opposite of freedom so i
can totally understand if
you know you wanted them to opt out of
that but
talk to me how does that work because
they're not going to school do they have
friends how can they have friends if
they're moving from country to country
so that's uh you know in the beginning
we traveled really fast and and
yeah and we we are now adjusting to slow
travel so we stayed for five months on
politico before that five months island
now two three months in mexico so so we
are slowing down the pace because
of the social context and everything um
the kids the first two years we
unschooled them uh because if you want
to respect your kids
uh you can't just stop the normal thing
and go into online schooling you just
unschool them you just stop
you just let them be kids for some time
so that they get in this new rhythm of
life
and then from that moment on uh when the
reset was done let's say that they
were getting used and to be not going to
school
and then we started to homeschool and
online school then there are beautiful
projects like galileo which is an online
school
for digital nomad families where all
kids
yeah they gather every morning for 30
minutes in a zoom call
with more than 12 kids talking about the
things that kids will
want to learn and and they guide the
kids in their
um they're tragic my daughter wants to
learn about the stars and about the sea
and about elephants so that month she
will spend that and their coaches will
help her to find subjects to read
write and investigate that event or the
stars so it's a different style of um
of educating but they still learn my
youngest kid
i've never gone to school her name is
jessa she's not 10 years old
she's never gone to school she writes
she reads
she speaks english she speaks dutch she
understands german
tries to speak german and she knows a
lot about animals she knows a lot about
human mindset connecting people
so they learn different things in
different ways and it also has
disadvantages this lifestyle has
disadvantages it big disadvantage
should be social context of course there
is a lot of
digital moment families we we have a
huge group of more than 50 families that
we meet all over the world and we live
in a few months in portugal
and then in thailand so the kids can
connect but it's different than they go
to school in a daily days
but nowadays the difference isn't that
big anymore
all the world is homeschooling you know
and even when we visit the netherlands
most children are not playing football
on the streets anymore
they are at home playing fortnite or any
other computer game
the world is changing and we can fight
against it and we try
and we try to minimize the use of
telephones and laptops for a kiss
but when we try it as a family and we
send them out to play with other kids
but there are no other kids on the
street
it's it becomes more normal so they have
snapchat they have facebook they have
all that stuff they have digital friends
they have friends all over the world
where they have you know chat with every
day
in different languages and sometimes we
go back to the netherlands to pick up
the
friendships that they had in the schools
when you still went to school
you know but it's you become part of a
huge family which calls itself the
digital moment family
and we are not the only family we are
the only family that went all into
bitcoin probably
but all the other families they do other
digital normal work
they do podcast they do coaching and
they
develop websites but there are so many
people traveling
you know i think it's natural i think if
you go back 50 years or 100 years
we all were nomads we were um we were
people that were traveling we started to
go and live in villages and cities
because of the jobs
jobs were created the industrial
revolution made us
go there and live there and get that
same education
and same job but now now we are going
into the new age
where jobs are being disconnected from a
location
i can work from home i can work online i
can even work for a company on different
locations in the world
so i see us as humanity shifting them
back
to nomadic lifestyles where we make the
use
of the tools of blockchain and bitcoin
that make it able to have this
decentralized lifestyle
that you make use of houses all over the
world cars whatever you need
we already see the preface airbnb and
all that stuff
you know that's the pre-phase this is
going to be houses
only on the blockchain in the future
that you and me
will be paying the time that we spend
that's a new nomadic way of living and
that's
because we get a universal currency
cryptocurrency maybe bitcoin another one
maybe a central bank's digital currency
whatever you believe
but it is going that way in my opinion
i'm sorry
no no no no i i do agree with you i'm
just fascinated
um by the homeschooling and the digital
nomad syllabus for the kids i'm really
fascinated by that and
i'm also fascinated by how they'll turn
out
you know in comparison to how the the
let's just say the average
child going to school turns out these
days i sort of i sort of feel like we're
um schooling is very much to prepare us
to work in the factories
and to work for the man and so on and so
on so i'm just
i'm so interested to see how the digital
nomad child grows up
you know what it is like if these
schools are still preparing those kids
for those jobs
in 10 years times there is no job in the
factory anymore
it's robots being building cars it's
robots doing everything
how can you prepare kids for that you
know i will give you an example i would
thought my oldest daughter now to become
an entrepreneur like
i was walking on the beach i was doing a
video and she was like
dad i want to make my own bitcoins i'm
15. you know i need to be independent
okay um let's let's think about how you
can become
bitcoins because there's no employee
that's going to pay you bitcoins yet
and then she's like yeah i don't know
how so maybe you'd like to design a
beautiful
t-shirt and then she said no no i want
to i want to design a hoodie
so i taught her the whole process so on
the beach we were thinking about what
kind of food he needed to be yeah it
needs to be a pink hoodie
and it needs to be something with
bitcoin on it so i went home with her to
the apartment i thought okay so now we
are going to do it let's see how
difficult or how easy it is we went on
to fiverr
i told her look we are going to ask
people to design a cool original
bitcoin logo from that hoodie and she's
like what are they how much are they
going to ask
let's see what they offer so we put the
you know
we put the project online at fiverr they
gave us an offer i told her did not
negotiate the guy
asked ten dollar i told her to offer two
dollars at the end she paid four dollars
for the
for the logo then we went to her online
shop you know that's just drop shipping
uh i told her this this is the pink
hoodie we pasted the logo on it and then
she was like wow ready
who's going to buy it that is now the
next step that is marketing
so we called it um we texted uh the
bitcoin team you know for twitter as
well
and ask her hey if i send you this
hoodie pink one
bitcoin would you please wear it in one
of your twitters or your videos or
whatever
and she said yes so my daughter was like
oh she's connecting to another team
she's selling her the hoodie for free
she was wearing it and we sold 40 of
those hoodies that month
so in one month i had educated
her completely in the concept of just
being creative in your mind
using all the stuff that is already
there designers
online shipment marketing and
putting that into a concept which makes
you bitcoin
and that lesson told my kids way more
than any autonomy
that i have read on the higher economics
but that's how i totally i totally agree
with you by the way just want to let you
know that your camera's frozen
oh you've actually started moving again
you're okay so your camera's frozen but
i can hear you perfectly
um i can't see you now it's okay it's
okay it's kind of the issue that we had
before we went live
but oh no i think i think we're okay i
think we're okay
um yeah
no you're fine you're moving and your
voice is fully clear so it's fine to be
honest
um but that that's unbelievable and that
is
the best education that is the ultimate
education that
um people or kids of the future need not
this
bs in school about i'm sorry i'm going
to say like algebra
and the cell of a plan and and all this
stuff you know
it's just insane but in terms of living
off bitcoin so
you've never sold it is that right
you've never sold it
no i exchanged bitcoins to stable
currencies to buy back more bitcoins but
we never went back to bank accounts
because we don't own a bank account
anymore
already for four years so how do you how
do you buy things and you know some
places obviously aren't always going to
be
crypto friendly so how do you purchase
stuff especially airbnb is that how you
get your
your um your homes so it becomes more
easy and more easy in the beginning it
was difficult but nowadays it's not
difficult anymore you know you have all
online booking sites that accept bitcoin
already
i don't know if you can name them we get
travala excel trip these are all like
bit by flight flight by bit you can buy
your flights your bouquet
all the hotels i can book on booking.com
or apartments
i can book with bitcoin directly so the
house is not that difficult anymore
um all the other stuff i just need to
convince people
you know when i arrived at portable i
found a beautiful house in airbnb that i
want to run for a few months and i text
private and you need all kinds of crazy
to reach them with the number
because
airbnb blocks this of course and then i
got income
i got into contact i went there and i
said can we have a barbecue i want to
rent your house for six months
we had a bbq at dinner i told them we
are the bitcoin family i showed him an
article in french because it was a
french owner
and i told him i want to pay him bitcoin
and that is how you can get the double
for your house in the next couple of
months and he's
left but he agreed so the house was
covered i walked to the beach to the
beach bar and then the beach brothers
guys go polo and paulo was there
asking me for the bitcoin t-shirt i told
them yeah we travel the world can i
spend bitcoins at your bar
please can i spend them at the end of
the week and we uh you know make a bill
because the fees are a little bit too
high in bitcoin i educate them about the
fees
then i start a wallet on their telephone
and that whole week i drink my buckeye
cokes my lunches on the beach and
at the end i paid in bitcoin this guy is
now calling me and he's like wow did he
in two weeks time i made double just
because the increase in the privacy
that's also bitcoin
and that's how it with the sailing
knockoff and
portugal that's how i did it with the
hotel here in mexico
that's how i do it with the restaurants
for all the other cases
we use all those online platforms like
bit refill where we buy
coupons to spend at the meccans or where
we buy a coupon to spend it
alibaba or at whatever online shopping
and then we still of course at the end
we have a bitcoin debit card
and with the debit card of course i can
pay all over the world as well
these are supported non-kyc debit cards
kyc debit cards
you became very creative in the last
couple of years
and we are using any possible tool to
just live on bitcoin
for us it's surpassing the banking
system and we are succeeding in this
already for four years now
which is the non-kyc debit card you're
using if you don't mind me asking
i will i will send you that in the
private chat okay thank you
i'm just curious about that one that
one's interesting um
that's so cool i bet the the guy in
portugal must have been
absolutely over the moon because when
you arrived
it was what at the end of 2020 so
bitcoin was just about to hit new
all-time highs
so he would have doubled his money uh i
thought to pay all the bills when
bitcoin was around 20k
20k and it's now 60k so yeah the guy
he doubled not only but he started to
call me during that time
and he's like are we going higher 30
cases yes so he started to buy bitcoins
more and more
and he started to tell his friends in
portugal again
you should be buying bitcoins so this is
a small thing you can do as a bitcoiner
because you believe you go to a bar
you have a chat so you have fun you have
a drink
you have a chat and you have the chance
to convince somebody to understand
and believe the whole bitcoin concept
and and
maybe you use it avoid paying taxes
maybe he will use it
um you know for for any other reason
that doesn't matter
bitcoin is for everybody but we as a
community should start to educate
everybody
i made a video today about i could
upload it in an hour or something it's
about
you know that i can see that people are
seeing bitcoin more than a financial
tool to accumulate wealth or to protect
wealth
and the video today i will post on
youtube i imagine people on
it's not only that it's also a
disruptive
immutable 24 7 usable borderless
peer-to-peer cash that is going to
involve everybody into the humanitarian
system
it's more than just accumulating wealth
it's changing the world we
you me all the influencers we are
changing the world
maybe we don't realize it yet i do but
in 10 years time
we will look into these videos and we
will like we were at the forefront of
changing this whole monetary system into
a
harness one that is now accessible for
everybody
and everybody still has full control
on their money that's a change that we
need to make
though we are making it i love that
you're converting people on the way i
think that's my favorite part of this
you're just like kind of hustling your
way through this and you're just like
guys
trust me you're gonna double your money
let me pay you in bitcoin
but i have a question for you so what
happened
back in 2017 um during the bear market
you know went from 20k down to 3k i know
you are obviously still in profit
because you bought in at 900
but were you concerned that you'd made a
mistake
no we were not completing profits we
started to buy 900. my pension fund
went in at 6 000 us all up at bitcoin um
but of course we changed a little bit on
the top like 20 30
we changed it to the stable bond and you
know um
for us we had this new mindset of living
minimalism
it was not about the money anymore we
were prepared to lose everything
if only we could change life the money
that we didn't care it was you know and
we came into this rollercoaster ride
because of the move
uh documentaries were being made
interviews they they were invasive
invading our life completely we didn't
even have time to think about selling
bitcoins and trading it was
our life was disrupted in a way that you
can't imagine we would live in a
campsite they were flying from
wall street was flying was um australia
ukraine
our life was like we couldn't even see
what we were doing at that point and
you know and in 2018 and 19 yeah
life costed us about one to two bitcoins
a month
but now lighthouse is lost one bitcoin a
year you average out you know it's
that's the strange thing
you drive this scholar roller coaster
ride but
you know in the beginning when we made
the huge kind of profits
we took almost 36 percent i think i i
still have the calculation summary man
and we gave that to children and and
then we had these dip from 12k to 6k
which i didn't expect and then 6k to 3k
which i didn't expect but we just needed
3k a month to live life so for us there
was not an issue we were just looking a
simple line in thailand
and now yeah now now we have a little
bit more luxuries now you know this year
my kids asked me the first time in
portugal
can we now for once spent christmas in a
house so
portugal you i rented a beautiful villa
you know which rule everything now
mexico we have a penthouse with a
private pool
because now i show the kids if you'd
just take two steps back
for two years and don't spend too much
and try to save your bitcoins
you can live life to the fullest now
here in mexico you know and we are
building
a school in mexico for poor kids still
all the profit i make
youtube books t-shirts trading
everything goes into a fund and i use
this fund to
help poor people all over the world we
are building a school in tulum here for
very poor kids and we are buying a house
in venezuela 20
home kids without parents we are doing
i'm just giving it away
because i discovered the secret of life
is not about greed and accumulating
it's about giving the more you give the
more you receive
the more you give happiness the more you
receive happiness the more you give
money away the more it comes back from
other ways in life
it's a it's a completely different
lifestyle maybe
some people think it's floaty or flowy
whatever you call it hippie
i i i don't know you know we we do it
that way and it's our way
we try to lead by example some people
will like it some people won't
i respect everybody if you want to buy a
lamborghini from your profits happy
i'm very respected to you you do it if
you want to build a school
i also respect you know it's we are all
different people and we need to start to
learn to respect each other for our
opinions
whatever opinion it is yeah i think
you know you definitely attract what you
put out there i say you know
the happier you the happier you are for
other people the more happiness will
find you it's all about having that
abundance mindset and i think you were
rewarded
for your minimalism because imagine if
you
had actually splashed out during that
bear market
you know and you were living in all
these luxury places then
you wouldn't be able to have what you
have now um so
you were totally rewarded for your
minimalism exactly and i think everybody
will
be rewarded for their minimalism not
only in money but also
in happiness if people learn to
understand that not having their back on
your
luggage or your bag of a house and all
that stuff
you you can't i can't explain how much
freedom this will give you
you know as a man i always had this
pressure on my shoulders you know
you need to provide you need to have
security you need to have a house you
need to have cars
when i couldn't let go of that thought
and just be there for the family and
have happiness the life changed
completely it's it's strange it's i
don't know how it works
i just agree uh on that award and i just
go yeah there absolutely
do you do you have any belongings then
like how light
do you travel like how light are we
talking you've obviously got some
laptops and some phones
but what else have you got so we travel
always with four backpacks
so all we belong is in those four
backpacks and we have
of course four backpacks but we also
have um how do you call it
uh that laptop back once so we have uh
yeah a trolley let's say trolley with
the laptops and the cameras and
everything
but the clothes and all the other
belongings are for backpacks we don't
own anything
we don't own anything we have a car in
madrid in spain now park the bitcoin car
the one that you
saw driving but um that was kind of
sponsored and it's not even registered
on our name but we are driving it
um but um no we there's no ownership of
anything
we have a few boxes stored in spain and
my parents-in-law
that contain my pictures for my father
and mother
um that contain the kids
um how do you say this the the things
that kids care about from the past
yeah their pictures are there but that's
like five boxes or something in spain
and the rest is just
yeah what we travel with backpacks
i'm i really
i'm honestly envious i love it so much
my heart
just like is just filled with warmth i
really love it honestly
i'm wondering we have quite a few people
watching right now we have quite a few
questions i'm wondering whether you'd
fancy doing an ama
um if people want to write in some
questions would that be okay with you
um it's 10 to 10 yeah we can i still
have
yeah we still have done that let's do it
yeah how long do you have
about like 10 minutes or something like
that
no we have more than like 25 minutes
okay cool all right so guys if you're
interested we're gonna do an ama so just
write your questions
now for the bitcoin family and we'll go
through it
so there is one question actually which
i'm just going to scroll up on
um somebody asked about taxes and that's
a really interesting one so
which country do you belong to where are
you a citizen of
you know who owns you basically
so we have a dutch passport and
if you become creative and as a digital
nomad you don't need to be registered
anywhere
you can travel and as long as you don't
have bank accounts there is no way that
they
can force you or make you or have you
pay taxes because you're living off your
capital
in the netherlands you have a capital
tax um of 1.3
so if i would be registered in another i
would be paying 1.3
and portugal you pay zero percent on
bitcoin so if you register in portugal
you have zero percent of bitcoin
in mexico you also have zero percent on
bitcoin and switzerland you also still
have 0
so in many countries um you could be
registering to uh to just avoid paying
tax on your cryptocurrencies
be aware we still don't have bank
accounts we don't have any assets
so it becomes more easy you don't have
that and only have cryptocurrency you
just choose that country it doesn't tax
cryptocurrency
and you need to just let go of that
other country so
i know it's different for people living
in the us uh they still
protect us even if they register in
other countries but i was lucky to be a
dutch
citizen and then there is more
opportunities yeah
so yeah i actually no go for it sorry
what are you going to say
so i'm not against uh paying taxes i'm
against how the systems build up i think
it's i think it's stupid
i think they still don't understand that
they can just turn around the tax system
in a
in like in a minute and have everybody
pay taxes
uh but that's that's attempt to um you
do find out how that works
but you know as long as i need to pay
taxes i will pay my taxes
but you know percent political zero
percent so
i'm pretty happy you're doing good
somebody asked um
but what about access to exchanges you
need to show utility bills but
you don't need an exchange do you you
don't exchange
so we we used that at the beginning like
kraken and all this stuff in 2016 so
that one is the only one
when i was still educating myself in
this industry but nowadays we use the
non-kyc exchanges to trade you know i'm
not using
which okay we'll see a change anymore
you know it's uh i i don't have the need
to buy
altcoins anymore on those kyc regulated
exchanges
and i will trade bitcoin i will trade
all the coins that it's possible to
trade on those non-kyc exchanges
and i will buy my bitcoin peer to peer
otc deals along the beach while i'm
drinking my bugatti gold
with that otc dealer i i have a journey
i learned a lot about it but i also
learned that the community is that big
now
but everybody now and then is in the
need to sell or buy
bitcoins and you as a community can
solve this
it worked the same time and the same way
in history
you were actually your ex for milk we
didn't need any
government or governance or government
or bank
to make us a camille correct you don't
need those people anymore to live and to
eat bitcoins for money or whatever
it's all possible it's not that
difficult anymore sorry
how long no no oh my god don't apologize
i'm honestly absolutely fascinated i
love it this is this is my dream so i'm
living vicariously through you right now
um while we're in lockdown here in the
uk so there you go um
but when do you see bitcoin being
um widely adopted so i know we're seeing
loads of institutions jumping in right
now and it's obviously helping with the
price action
but how do you see bitcoin playing out
do you see it you know
people doing what you're doing and
living off it and it being that global
currency
or do you think things will sort of
continue as they are they'll evolve but
it'll be more of a store of value like
gold is
yeah so yeah i i have my opinion on this
but um you know
i also need to say up front i'm not a
financial advisor or anything else and
i also think we live day by day so it
can go in any direction
bitcoin will stand to be a peer-to-peer
cash
and at the moment the fees are too high
to be a peer-to-peer cash
and if the second layer applications
will evolve
like liquid or lightning network maybe
it will be converted to your cache
if not it was baked into a hot uh way
that
into the software that we can hard fork
it which makes it possible to be
at all the other currencies developed
that maybe will evolve to peer-to-peer
cash
um i i'm not a member of this maximum as
maximus in the way of
i only love bitcoin i love the community
i think we as a community need to work
together
all currencies to disrupt the monetary
system
so not fight each other i'm better you
better no we
fight the monetary system whatever
cryptocurrency succeeds in becoming p2p
cash
in my opinion at the moment i see the
bitcoin movement
going more into the store value and i
can see it becoming the new
uh 21st century gold i can see it
becoming the most important tool
in the world not for us anymore but for
governments
bought for countries and and you see
this already if you read through the
news
you can exactly see what is happening
i'm going to try to explain it very
shortly
so 12 months ago i started to read
articles about iran iraq pakistan
venezuela turkey that they were
incentivizing their power plans to mine
bitcoins countries incentivizing their
power plans to mine bitcoins
those countries were all the countries
that were
under the u.s sanctions they didn't get
dollars anymore to do input and export
they mined bitcoin for 12 months and now
the last couple of months they came out
and they said
now we as a country pakistan iran
venezuela turkey
we are going to use bitcoin legally for
import
and export so they are bypassing the u.s
sanctions
china wants to be the biggest bitcoin
miner the united states wants to be the
biggest bitcoin miner
all countries want to be the biggest
bitcoin miner why do you think that it's
happening
it is not because they think it's a scam
of multi-level marketing
it is because they as governments as
central banks are creating a new
monetary system
they are crashing this current monetary
system to create a new one
which is called central banks digital
currencies and those central banks
digital currencies are going
to be backed up by digital gold and that
is why
that is the only reason that all those
billion dollar companies
billionaires now got a legal framework
to put bitcoins on their balance sheet
to buy
bitcoins because the politicians allowed
it and when politicians start to make a
framework and allow those billion dollar
companies to buy
bitcoins you know that there is a bigger
game going on because those donors
will be backing up their politicians
during the new run for president
that is how economics work bitcoin is
going to be goal of the 21st century
and all the billion dollar companies and
billionaires are now already
exchanging their reserve currencies into
that new
store of value goal and the banks are
playing the same game
they played with gold we were used to
have our gold
in our homes we as a coil boy or indians
we had a house
full with gold then we were getting
afraid because there were some people
telling us oh but you can be robbed
and then the banks evolved and then the
people were
putting their gold into banks to keep
them safe
and then the banks were custodial
service for your gold
do you see the dots now the banks are
becoming custodial servers
for people's bitcoins they are playing
the game over and over and over again
we need to educate those people yes
the bank can you'll be the custodial
service but that is not your bitcoin
not your key not your bitcoin so for me
i think bitcoin is still evolving to be
this digital gold of the 21st century
but on the other hand i still have the
hope that the community will see this in
time
and will still understand this
revolution of disrupting the monetary
system and
taking back the power to the people when
it comes to finance to life
to everything else because that is what
bitcoin and blockchain for me is about
i think you make a really interesting
point you know when you talk about the
banks
and custodial services because this is
such a debate
in the community and it's it's this
community is just full of debates and
controversies
and there's this whole idea you know not
your keys not your coins and i'm very
much of the mindset you know not your
keys not your coins but i also believe
that eventually not everybody will want
to hold
their own um their own keys you know if
this thing really does go mainstream
i just i don't think everybody will want
that kind of responsibility
i agree with you and i don't think it's
needed because
just just just see it i see it as a
revolution but other people see it just
an evolution
it's just minus the r it's the same word
i put the r before
in front of it but um for me you need to
understand like the
the monetary system now is built in the
same way you have
money and it's digital on bank accounts
and you have cash
you're using them both the the thing is
now that if this cash is going to fall
away
because there is only seven percent left
in the world that is still physical cash
or coins
if that is going to go away we still
need to have an alternative way of
hauling and spending money as cash
digital cash now
and that's the only thing people
understand if you would play it safe
keep your money on the bank but be sure
to support the revolution that there is
an alternative for that money
because that money can be frozen like we
saw in greece like you saw in cyprus ibc
all over the world
appear to peer cash they can't freeze it
it's yours
and as long as people understand that
there's two systems and you can use all
both systems for me i don't hate banks
no for people love banks let them know
banks
i just want to educate people on this
alternative way of keeping track of
their finance or keeping control on
their finances and that's the
pure cryptocurrency um so
i don't see a future with only
decentralized money i see a future with
centralized parties having centralized
money let them play their game
but i want to be part of that other side
of the world and i don't want to have
control
i don't have control of a centralized
organization bank or institution that
will call me at the end of the month and
tell me
we saw you bought six bottles of uh
bakari this month
your alcoholist we're going to freeze
the town because you drink too much
i don't want that control i don't want
the social credit system like it is in
china
and i don't want a combination of a
financial social credit session
uh credit system combined with digital
fiat hold by the bank that commission is
awful
that's awful i can't that's a that's a
horror movie for me
no i'm totally with you
yeah yeah no i'm totally with you no
don't stop apologizing honestly i'm
really fascinated by this and i think
i think you make such a good point in
that um people now have a choice and
that's what bitcoin gives you know
it's not about forcing people to take
personal responsibility it's about
educating them and we now have a choice
so i know that you are
um a little bit pushed for time but one
last question um which is really
interesting
somebody has said what would you
recommend to someone who
who doesn't have any bitcoin but wants
to live just as freely as you what would
your advice be
at the moment yeah if they want to live
as free as you
but they don't have any bitcoin what
would you advise them
sell everything you have go all into
bitcoin
yeah ride the bull run to top
a few weeks before the top exchange your
bitcoin into a stable coin
use a huge part of that stable coin to
stake level those high yields
while we go into the bear market in the
bear market bottom
you buy your bitcoins and you ride the
next four year cycle
and you will be living the same way in
beautiful houses maybe i don't know if i
can move
but i can move i will move and i will
show you
it's not only me it's also you guys out
there
that can live with a view of this here
it's on the beach yeah we can see
it's a little bit frozen but we can see
wow i can see it's beautiful
that is possible for everyone and it's
cheaper than paying my mortgage for a
house in the netherlands
oh my gosh absolute goals
absolute goals i tell you um dd i want
to thank you so much i've been so
excited to chat to you i'm so pleased
that we were able to do this i know
you're moving around a lot but
i think it was really cool that we were
able to schedule schedule this
um so thank you so much for coming on um
you're completely welcome i apologize
again that i
needed to do it one hour earlier we are
going to go on a boat trip
with a guy living here in mexico and he
has built a hotel
somewhere here on a beautiful beach and
it will be bitcoin blockchain hotel so
i'm going to have a boat trip and talk
with him
and advise him on how we can uh build
this beautiful place here in mexico
together
thanks so much i love what you're doing
for the crypto community and i really
respect you
i love that there are more and more
women in this community and we need them
because they always keep the community
cool fair and honest
and that's what i like about it thank
you so much for having me on your
shoulder
yeah thank you so much for coming and
enjoy your boat trip
and i think that's so cool that you're
going to teach them all about bitcoin so
thank you so much again thank you
everybody for watching and don't forget
to tune in next week
see you soon enjoy your day bye bye keep
believing keep believing
there you go see you later